all right guys bang-bang Tyrone is back
round 2 he's got the long Bitcoin short
the banker shirt on he's ready to roll
it's going up alright for those that
didn't listen to the first episode that
we did together and don't follow you on
the internet which at this point seems
impossible maybe he just start with kind
of a two minutes on your background and
kind of the work that you've been doing
yeah really quick so before I start this
again thank you again for having manases
incredibly dope about the Byrne
Internet's down so I'm excited so for
those who don't know me born and raised
here in New Jersey one of the things I
hold my hat on is being a first
generation high school graduate and
obviously first interracial college
graduate as well part of reasons why I'm
super you know passionate about crypto
was growing up in an unbaked home I got
a full scholarship to run track went to
Georgia Tech was also the first of my
family to get kicked out of college
so left Georgia Tech I ended up at Seton
Hall where I finished up my bachelor's
there and then started a graduate
program where I actually learned about
Wall Street
I was 26 years old before I knew
anything about the stock market or
anything like that so right now
currently licensed financial advisor um
director of community at altruist and
hosted a human adviser podcast not as
big as yours but got my own podcasts out
there trying to follow in your footsteps
so south of my out to his family also
founder of a company called 401 which is
a storytelling consultancy um that I did
I launched in April of this year um and
then the other piece of that is again a
lot of work that I do bringing light to
unbanked poverty homelessness child
hunger and I do a lot of speaking and
engagement on that as well and again for
those who don't realize or know @tr for
one you're on Twitter you get you get
the host feel so there's a couple people
who are tweeting me asking
what is altruist so let's just start
there I seen the podcast yeah it makes
every other podcast look like nobody
knows what they're doing because the
super high quality I said I've never
seen a podcast where somebody walks down
the street in her cords respect the hell
out of it so what exactly is altruist
yes allude to that so altruists is a
technology platform for financial
advisors they're basically trying to be
the digital Schwab or the digital TD on
a shout to Jason Wang who's a genius so
his whole thing is to make it cheaper
for financial advice for our is only so
registered investment advisors only
making it cheaper for them to run their
practices their tech stack so that then
they can in turn work with a different
demographic so that's hence the name
altruist they reached out to me July of
last year about hosting a podcast and
I'm like I'm pumped like I got high and
I'm not trying to host no podcast
ok I'm off that I don't want no smoke
with him but Jason was like listen you
told you a story we think that we could
do something different here
um with you helping advisors tell their
stories and just really getting away
from the jargon and everything and I'll
keep it a buck we change the game that
there's no way you could turn on that
podcast and relate it to any other thing
that's in our business financial
services there's nothing like it
so shout to everybody else wish to work
on that we completely turn the game on
its ear and I said it all time like I
literally have mentees that are in gangs
that are like your next podcast is
gangster and then I get you know people
from all over our businesses like you
know clients and everything love it so
we definitely change the game with that
I just love the human aspect of it right
and I think that like what we're
starting to understand is legacy media
has been so focused on like what's the
story and not so much I'm like let me
tell the let me let the people of the
story tell their own story right it's a
it's a new way to do it you guys are
doing a great job there and any specific
story that you guys have covered there
that really stands out to you is like
man that was either one an awesome story
or two you kind of walked away we're
just like I'm so glad I decided to do
this yeah great question is funny you
front-running me a bit because I got a
piece coming out the details there's a
whole season but I will say
the one that sticks out the most is
probably the very first episode um that
we did where it was like we literally
got the first advisors the first true
episode was was me and Jason out of CEO
and it's Leah Miko and again I wonder
this podcast is not scripted right
there's only one scripted question that
we asked at the end and that's what
makes it so dope is like the guests
trust me
right because we just sit down we turn
on two cameras and we have a
conversation and LeAnn is telling her
story and I'm literally listening to the
woman version of my old life I get first
generation high school graduate grew up
poor like you know and she's a white
woman who's a lesbian but and if she's
being interviewed by a black man right
we grew up on different sides of the
country but that humanity in that story
we were almost one right and I'm just I
mean we got so lost in the conversation
and when we don't we got we wrapped
everybody was like oh that was dope like
you know I mean it was just so real so
it to me right then it was like alright
we're on to something here because we
got so far away from our business but
just into what made her her and then I'm
like man she had the same experience
that I had and then you start to realize
that poverty and poor is not a color
right it's not it's a condition you know
mean and even for those of us that reach
the quote-unquote heights of financial
services we all have a story so it was
pretty neat yeah I love that
and then you uh you you are the person
or one of the people who helped me edit
a piece that I recently wrote and you
know you know we're talking and I said
to you look I think I've got these
unique life experiences that helps me
understand as a white dude how to talk
about some of these issues that most
people just never see right and it was I
literally still with a gun in a war zone
right and I've also been next to a bunch
of black teammates in college who just
frankly just racist ass situations that
happen and I wrote this thing I sent it
to you and you came back to me and I
loved it because you the advice you gave
was not the grammatical stuff right it
was much deep
more important than that around like hey
let's use some more kind of important
quotes right let's let's look at this
type of framework so maybe talk a little
just about there's so many people right
now who are online who are watching kind
of I'll call the 2020 chaos happen so
you've got the coronavirus occurs then
you've got the economic shock then
you've got the civil rights and kind of
all the police brutality protests and
even turning into riots in some cases
and it just feels like social media
makes it seem like the world's ending we
know it's not ending we know we live in
the most prosperous time in human
history but it also feels like a lot of
the people who are standing up and
saying things don't come out of the
finance world as much just really talk a
little bit about kind of how you see the
world today and then also you're kind of
the interaction or the intersection with
finance right so I'm glad you brought
that up because I was gonna bring it up
eventually the piece that you wrote was
fantastic and again kudos to you for
using your voice at a time when so many
with that look like you and have the
platform that you have want to hide and
so kudos to you for that for reaching
out it's been like oh man read this over
right and I'll be honest I was like man
you probably want to say black and not
minority a lot right like you want to
leave this is a black issue so you know
those are and it sucks we can't tell the
DMP story right now too but whatever
this fits so nice right here but but
honestly though like thank you for doing
that because again it brings light to
everything that is going on and yes we
are in a time where we're still in the
middle of the greatest wealth transfer
the world has ever seen we're in the
middle now again which is the civil
rights movement of this era there's
tremendous income inequality financial
illiteracy so many different issues and
again like you said right now those of
us with a platform have a responsibility
yes we'll address the issue but to be
more solution oriented and I will also
say those of us that are black that have
been in financial services already knew
that these were issues I've been saying
this forever right for the last 18 years
I've been saying this and screaming into
the forest but now it's become a thing
so let's just address some of the issues
right our business right and I say ours
if I as a financial advisor seventeen
billion dollars the financial services
industry spends on marketing financial
services less than one percent on
financial education that's sickening
right when you look at almost half of
the population do not own stop let's not
forget for one second this is an
economic issue also financial advisors
are complicit we sell our services to
the rich don't necessarily give our time
to the poor right and then when you look
at the numbers the Poor People's
Campaign of America says there's roughly
a hundred and forty million people in
this country that are considered poor
right um you look at the numbers before
Kovac we're 50 million quote-unquote
working poor right all of these
different numbers the almost twenty
percent that are unbanked all of these
different things again which is why I've
never been more bullish on crypto than I
am right now so I think what we see is
civil unrest but within it our seeds of
resolution right of solution and people
who want to be effective in in in
uniting right of bringing really core
solutions to the problem so that's what
I feel like I want to do but I don't
think we get there unless there are
people again like yourself who are
address some of the again this is
systemic and structural right so we
gotta put those together and also
embrace in our history I just got done
with a panel I was saying this oh well
financial services is very you know Mayo
pale and stale as they say okay well
let's go all the way back to the origin
of Wall Street slaves built Wall Street
and then they turned around and sold
them and then in 1711 the United States
government says New York City is the hub
for all face lavery now you want your
good old slave go down to New York City
right so and then there's this whole
thing about black Wall Street no black
Wall Street has always Walsh it has
always been black like we were the first
commodity sold and it wasn't until
coffee came and it was big thing they're
like okay well let's move on to
something that is more lucrative and or
cleaner and that's when the slave trade
eventually left New York City so I think
it - we start to dig into the muck here
right and really start to address some
of these issues we won't progress but
again you're starting to see some of the
statues come down and some you know a
lot of other conversations now that are
being had people are having
conversations like this the piece that
you wrote we got to get uncomfortable a
little bit and it will move on last
thing I'll say is it is incredibly funny
to me that and I think this is why
you're able to stand up and take
Internet bullets cuz you've taken real
bullets like literally when in a fear
where a gun so it's like it's it's super
powerful when you stand up and say that
because again you know people look at
you and go oh man he has a lot more to
lose than I but he's standing up and
taking a stand and the financial
services industry has dropped the ball
here it's been it's been sad but again
kudos to you for what you've done
um and make a room for the conversation
and now it's a company pound those of us
that are black especially black males to
now take this to say okay well what are
we gonna do to make it better for our
community yeah what's interesting to me
about the entire situation right and
when I say entire situation there's a
race element there's a police-brutality
element there's economic element and
they're very very intertwined so I'm not
gonna try to unpack either piece but
they're all very intertwined is really
what we end up getting is it's all
actually overlaid with a poverty like
lens right and and so what ends up
happening is you can take that poverty
lens and you can literally apply to the
economic situation obviously you can
apply to the race side you can apply to
the police brutality side and one of the
things that I've been thinking more and
more about is you can't solve a problem
unless you identify that it exists right
so okay so that's pretty easy then to is
where I think I've been did i disappoint
finally the right word actually is
there's a lot of people who they don't
want to have a realization of the truth
right I tweeted the other day and I said
that in order to actually seek the truth
right and I'm paraphrasing when I said
it was something like you gotta be able
have the uncomfortable conversations you
got to explore all the options right and
it just feels and that by the way works
in both directions right because here's
the other piece that I will say this
that I think is important to kind of
keep us intellectually honest is we get
in a world where everyone's protesting
police brutality and then we see a
situation where
cops shoot somebody and I always say
okay details really matter because
actually there's certain situations
where like if you're shooting at a cop
and the cop shoots back and kills you
I'm probably not gonna be up in the
street you know protesting about police
brutality if a cop shoots an unarmed man
I'm gonna be really pissed right like
the nuances matter and it's not so much
blanket statements but I do feel like on
the economic side you nailed it
financial education has been
non-existent right I mean just
absolutely non-existent across
socioeconomic status book who it really
predominantly hurts is that bottom fifty
percent that doesn't own stocks that
can't come with four hundred dollar
emergency payment like um they continue
and some of these people have actually
died and me and literally said to me I
feel like I cannot get ahead and and I
try to say look I can't give you
financial advice but let me just
understand a little bit more about your
situation and almost always they are
doing things that play right into the
hands of a system that is stacked the
deck against them right they're living
in all cash they don't make investments
they spend more than they make like all
these things so let me talk a little bit
about just like we know it's a problem
how do we start to solve this like what
are the things that we can do as an
industry and really it's just humans to
try to solve some of these problems yeah
I love how I love you asses because I
get so fired up about it and it's my
life's mission how so let's zoom out a
little bit right and I know a lot of
people have said you know they wanted to
make the distinction between protesters
rioters and looters
I want to focus on the looters for a
second look at what again it's
disgusting but again everything has its
place as my mother would say right but
let's just look at what they're stealing
they're running after their gods Gucci
Prada Fendi the idolatry in this country
and what we made them believe is
important to them are things not
educating them enough to say a Rolex a
Gucci bag comes out of you so we put
nothing in them so now we're looking at
the mirror of our failings also that's
one side then they go steal their needs
right to go to a Walmart
stealing from their right toilet-paper
dog food whatever the case may be that
is again a mirror of where our failings
are as a country no matter how you feel
about it and anybody that stare in the
mirror and honest with yourself some
things about yourself - maybe a little
uncomfortable I got this little patch
over here I need to get rid of right so
it's a very uncomfortable thing again we
I think we all agree we don't want to
tear down neighborhoods we don't want to
steal but that's how when you look at
the poverty in Detroit that I have seen
poverty all over this country you have
not seen poverty until you've seen
squalor in Detroit and then you go to
Beverly Hills and you look at the
difference and there's a man is worth a
hundred billion dollars in this country
and there are people literally who don't
have clean water that's what you're
seeing in the streets right now now ok
great Tyrone you address the issue how
do we fix it so now we have to focus on
solutions 3yz exposure education
empowerment our business likes to lead
with the big e the middle e because cfa
CFP wharton kellogg the whole deal let
me prove how smart I am no one cares
right if I can see it I can be it
so expose me to what it is right mister
whoever how did you get what you got
expose me to that give me the blueprint
right because I tell people this all the
time if all I give you is money I robbed
you but if I give you that money and in
turn give you the blueprint on how to
turn that dollar into $2 and then how I
was in the position to give you that
dollar I robbed you if I just gave you
money I get I did you no benefit so I
think that's the one thing that our
industry does very poorly right um and I
think that someone actually said this on
the podcast shot to Emma and he said our
business has done a good job of getting
the numbers right and the people wrong
and I think he nailed it with that one
and so now let's go to exposure now you
look at 31% of African Americans in this
country do not own stop right 31 I mean
31% do right so you have 60 almost 70%
that don't that's an access problem
that's an exposure problem which is wait
wait why I'm so fired up about
not only can you give Bitcoin but you
can get fractional shares of stock
through the app like that's powerful
Robin Hood
for all of the people that want to bash
it Robin Hood is access I don't care
what you think about whatever they're
doing or people day trading and beating
Warren Buffett that's access for people
that have never had access before so now
yes we have a responsibility now I've
exposed you now I have to educate you
but there's two types of ignorance
ignorance I just don't know and an
ignorance pop told me and I don't give a
crap right so I think we have to then go
in expose them educate them now the
biggest part is the last E which is
empowerment after I've done those two I
have to empower you meaning what I'm
going to give you a network I'm going to
give you continued resources I'm going
to give your school a technology
probably lack Wi-Fi you probably lack
tools that you need I'm going to give
you books we're going to create some
type of scholarship to come back we're
going to Bank black in that community or
we're going to Bank period in that
community so now when we need to do
financial literacy or financial
education in that city you know what
banks answer to really big deposits so
when you put really big deposit you go
give us some resources for these kids in
this school right not that same school
where the parents have put all the
resources or whatever this one here so
now we're getting into schools earlier
oh by the way financial advisor should
give up an hour of their time per day to
go into these schools support the
teachers help them with lesson plans or
whatever not to change the curriculum
but we have to be more success you know
accessible and then I think the last
piece of the empowerment is think about
this if all of the Blackstone Blackrock
Bank of America Morgan Merrill all of
them put in the fund and they said all
right take all the over for one trip for
one year we're gonna take all the
overdraft fees put it in the fund we're
gonna up that you know seven hundred
billion that we spend on you know
financial education you know to a
billion and we're gonna put that in the
fund and then we're gonna spend this to
simply educate you know a particular
area or city just for a test case and
then we can spread that all over America
take 25 of the best financial advisors
all
denominations all backgrounds all
Creed's all religions and have a tour go
all the way around the country instead
of us go into all these fancy
conferences and drinking ourselves silly
and there's SP palm trees in the lobby
right and then really start to educate
people and then oh by the way there's
some telephone ants where we call people
in the most impoverished areas in this
country is there anything that we can
help you with from a budgeting
standpoint personal finance standpoint
do you understand how your snap or your
EBT card works right are you getting
Social Security all these other things
are you up to date on your taxes are you
going to a tax preparer versus an actual
see a CPA all of these things granular
right and then you go into an area like
the South Bronx where half of the people
in the South Bronx are unbanked and then
you start to get really proximate and go
okay this is why they use payday lenders
and check cashing places in the post
office and then until we get proximate
to their condition we can't help them so
then we can give them the resources that
they need and then say okay well you
lack identity you lack a bank account if
you lack these things you can't do
anything else so we have to get you
these resources built infrastructure
around you and then oh by the way you'll
learn that these people are severely
illiterate in terms of what it means
that what is a maiden name what is the
debit what is a credit who cares about
your Roth conversion we get like we got
to get away from that so we have to get
on people's eye level and financial
advice and again I'm going long winded
here but I'm super fired up about it we
do a terrible job of giving people
financial advice a snapshot right where
you are college graduate high school
graduate mother of five whatever it is
right father of two and you know
corporate executive meet people right
where they are and give them the advice
in that moment if we do a better job of
that taking the advice to the people as
opposed to spending all this money and
then just say oh they'll come we have it
here right it's like if you if that's
the case then and I just had a
conversation what has to appear so she's
like are you aware of investor gov I'm
like I'm not and I feel terrible because
I'm a financial adviser but she's like
check out investor go there's a wealth
of information there people don't know
that's there they built it but if it's
not being brought to the people how did
no one's gonna help them yeah and I
think that one of the things that that's
really interesting to me is I've always
said to people many of the folks that
you're talking about have the skills
they don't know they have the skills
they don't know what to do but they
actually have the skills and I'll give
you a great example so when I was in my
mid-20s there was a program in North
Carolina that would go into the local
high schools right and they pretty much
were trying to pick any public school
within a certain radius whatever and
they would try to introduce
entrepreneurship classes right and the
class was we're gonna go for a week it's
an hour every morning and at the end
we're gonna have you quote-unquote start
a business so what most high schools
that have an entrepreneurship class is
like an after-school activity whatever
they somehow got in and they got an hour
of time dedicated in the morning while
the students were there and I went I
think two or three times during this
program and every time I would go a lot
of them were old white guys right they
were teaching this stuff and they were
trying to help and I would always say to
them I want those three guys and it was
always always the kids in the back of
the class that were sleeping that we're
doing whatever and when I'd get back
there they would why do you want to work
with them they're the troublemakers of
the class whatever I said cuz I got to
do the least amount of work to get them
to build a business they're gonna how to
build a business right and especially in
high schools you got up into the juniors
and seniors and stuff there's literally
one time when kid was like yeah I deal
drugs and I was like great you're gonna
guess what we're gonna just switch out
the product understand you understand
the man you understand supply you
understand supplies like like you got it
dude maybe let's not sell something
that's illegal I'm gonna maybe get you
in jail like we could start with a
t-shirt right and he start to like
understand and what I saw was he was the
most interested kid out of anyone I ever
saw in that program and it was because
he already had come to entrepreneurship
bug now that's not for everybody but at
the same time there's a lot of kids
especially a day with social media they
want the things as you described right
they want the Gucci bag they want the
car they want the house they want
whatever but nobody is there to tell
them this is how you get it right this
is how you kind of backwards plan off of
it and then one of the things that
cracks me up is people in tech all have
the same thing if I say to you hey how
do you build you know 100 million dollar
business you basically start doing math
backwards right okay well if I need a
hundred million dollars how much that a
month you know what product can I sell
what's the margins well and you start
doing math most people don't think that
way right they literally just say hey I
can't do that right or how do you buy it
I can't do that I couldn't afford that
it almost feels like the exposure is the
thing that drives the curiosity and will
kind of weed out the people who don't
want to be there right the people who
want to do this and they don't know it's
possible the second you show them it's
possible then it's game on
right and what it feels like and I'd
love to hear your thoughts it's like
once you start in a community with
exposing some portion of people and
they're the first to be exposed if it
works correctly eventually that becomes
the standard the expectation right it's
kind of like hey this is what we do and
that's true of going to college that's
true of financial education of whatever
but you guys start with exposure it
feels like yeah 1 percent it all starts
with exposure and this is what I yell
about on Twitter is like I get on other
things that you folks are talking about
but what they're just not exposed again
I am exhibit a I was 26 years old I
literally walked by the New York Stock
Exchange and didn't know what it was and
then when I got to the office the
gentleman who ultimately ended up my
mentor was like you know that was New
York Stock Exchange you just walk by and
no clue I'm 26 that's a disaster for
myself and my family everything I've
learned about money I've learned the
last 14 years on Wall Street like that's
literally a problem right and that is
indicative of our education system and a
lot of other things but also my parents
had no choice because they didn't have
it right so a lot of it is making sure
that it starts in the home but people so
well you blame the parents like well
would you want my parents to do they
were just trying to keep the damn lights
on they're not worried about shares of
frigging Amazon you mean like they're
just trying to make sure that you know
my sister and I could eat a naked so
financial planning and all that stuff is
meeting people where they are but again
now that I was exposed my nephews now
who are wanting to have portfolios
better than you don't mean probably I
have right they owned a ton of Bitcoin
right like so these are things that now
they're gonna benefit because I was
exposed right so and my niece
right says oh did my great-nephew so my
niece right there mother she was exposed
to me going to college so guess what she
was the second college graduate and now
she has her master's degree see how that
works right so if I see it now okay and
I and it's funny I was just telling us
the other day when I started to get
recruited for for colleges and I started
getting letters in the mail went to my
high school coach I'm like what are
these like why are they calling my house
he was like for college I'm like what do
you huh
like what is this why why would he want
to come to my house like my mother will
beat somebody up you don't want to just
come by my house no reason so he's like
no do you want to recruit you like I had
to learn that whole thing I've never
known anybody who went to college before
so the exposure is a very big piece and
I think that is probably the simplest
and cheapest part because it's just
simply exposing kids to that side to
this side right um and I think who was
it Kathy was named on by the CEO of
Merck was just saying the only reason he
ended up doing what he was doing is
because they decided to bust some kids
to the other side of school a town where
there's a program and then he was part
of that program and now look he's a CEO
of one of the biggest pharmaceutical
companies in the world
exposure matters and I don't think we
take that seriously enough so one of the
things that think's really important is
when we talk about financial education
you're not talking about by Amazon buy
this sell this short this whatever
you're specifically talking about what I
call like more structural education this
is how money works this is why inflation
works against you here's here's what
certain assets can do even things like
spend less than you make here's how a
credit card works here's what you want
to pay it off like that's the type of
stuff you're talking about right
absolutely you'll love this I've been
and it's so funny out his words I
literally am NOT sitting here without
investopedia and I've been blessed
enough to do some partnerships with
investopedia earlier this year was
sitting down with Caleb Caleb silver
shout to Caleb over investopedia he said
Tyrone the number one search term on
investopedia to a tune of a million page
views a month is what is money that is
the number one search term on
investopedia really a number one
like its head and shoulders above
everything else what is money again want
to talk about a failure as a country the
people literally don't know what money
is if you don't know what money is how
in the world do you do anything so
you're just operating blind and
literally he told me that and I stared
at him and I was like are you seasoned
million pageviews what is money like so
we have that and then there's this big
gap of just wilderness and we expect
people to get a job and then figure it
out right figure out a mortgage figure
out investments figure out your
retirement figure all of these things
out and then oh by the way we're going
to dangle all of this prosperity and
abundance when you look at you know the
the the numbers right 42 million
unemployed yet the billionaire's
continue to get richer to a tune of
whatever they all made collectively
right and it's it makes people feel like
you said you get those DMS where people
feel like they're falling farther behind
right and again I'm still in a situation
where my life is a lot different from my
families and my friends and people that
I know so I know people where $800 a
month is a lot of money to them right
like and they're still in the struggle
so being very close to that you realize
that the stock markets a liar and we
know that right for the people that are
invested and those of us that are
privileged to have investment accounts
Bitcoin and credit cards all life is
grand but the average person turning
that on and going what I understand how
in the world is that happening and I'm
furlough I got right and that is the
dude stock market but a stock market
right now is the biggest indicator of
the class issue that we have in this
country you thought the race issue is
bad the class issue which we're gonna
that's gonna come to a head to the class
issue is a bigger issue that we have to
solve it feels to me like this whole
idea of the stock market going up in
economic data getting worse ends really
poorly right and I'm
how it ends when it ends all that kind
of stuff but what I do feel is really
interesting is that it is the ultimate
highlighting of why financial education
matters right and their ultimate comes
down to if you understand when money
gets printed don't fight the Fed right
just ok cool we're printing you know
that asset prices are gonna rise get out
of cash and get into assets that one
piece of information which most people
in finance it's like you know economics
101 type stuff literally is the
difference between wealth and poverty in
2021
right I mean it's just crazy to me that
that's what we're talking about let me
ask you this
what do you see is the first foray so if
somebody goes from what we'll call not
well educated or not educated at all on
the financial side to okay I start to
understand this stuff what do they look
to do they want to buy stocks they want
to save like what do you see is some of
the first actions that they normally go
down and end up leading to being
successful financially really really
good question so and I feel like I have
a unique lens of this as an advisor so
one of the things that you constantly
and again we realize one of the biggest
issues here is debt consumer debt
student loan debt right so a lot of
questions that you get is how do I
manage just my financial life right like
and and debt leads the conversation I
have x amounted student loans I have X
amount in credit cards and one of the
things again whether a client comes in
and they have five million or they have
five dollars I say let's go all the way
back to square one
answer two questions for me one what is
your first memory of money is it your
grandfather walking you down to the bank
or is it scarcity like it was with me
the landlord banging on the door right
big difference how you operate as an
adult the other thing is now what is
your relationship with money right what
does that look like now you get money
what do you do is it in one hand and out
the other is it immediately to save is
it immediately to look for an
opportunity to flip like those are
habits so I asked those two question
the next thing is I don't care who you
are where are you from where you went to
school your color your favorite whatever
sports team give me three months of your
checking account I know all I need to
know about you how much you make where
you spend it how you spend it how often
you spend it I'll know everything about
you do that for yourself and then I tell
them I have them come back to me and
they're like oh right I spend X amount
of money eating out or I spend right cuz
you had no idea you were just operating
as if so that's one of the things just
getting people to understand the basics
and people just don't learn the basics
of really what it means to budget right
really what it means a personal finance
to make sure that I have these different
buckets for different things in my life
I've addressed the behavioral part of
myself when it comes to money those are
two big buckets the last bin is okay and
here's that here's the other thing is
people say well okay well I don't have
any leftover like all right fun right
visualize take a white piece of paper
draw a line down the middle everything
that comes in everything that goes out
you've got a number over here let's look
at that number that's called
discretionary income if you have a
number on the other side we got some
issues so we could address that just to
make sure people get even but now what
then do I do if I have that number over
here I have $100 left over right and
that's when you get the people diem and
you gonna buy airline stocks right or
whatever so you start to get into
alright and I was just having this
conversation about savings right now
let's look at that dial is you would
want savings and savings makes sense and
that's the ultimate goal six to one year
of savings based on whether you're
single married whatever ku savings is a
privilege right from growing up in a
house where savings was never a
compensated because there was nothing to
be saved if you could save it's a
privilege with that said there's
conversations where people say well I
have savings but I have credit card debt
I have savings but I have you know a
$700 car payment lab say well why do you
have savings right you should use some
of that savings to get yourself in a
better situation financially go all the
way back to what you're let's take your
credit cards what is your debt service
every more
right it's tickets costing you six seven
hundred dollars a month just to pay your
credit card bill so imagine if you took
some of your savings are all pay that
down now you're paying two hundred and
monthly credit card bills that leaves
you a $500 buffer now you could direct
that money to something else
we still haven't gotten to investments
yet we're just literally talking about
managing your financial life right and
then you can start to direct that
towards maybe a immediate savings bucket
or directing that to other payments that
you have again so so many different
things that people have um looking at
making sure they're maximize their work
benefits which a lot of people don't do
right um so those are really the
conversations and people want to get a
hold of and understand they just don't
know how to manage the finances of their
life right well how do I a liqu ate my
401k right what is this withholdings
thing right do i withhold one or ten or
zero no one knows that right there's no
education on that so it's really bare
bones basic personal finance but I take
everybody all the way back to the
beginning of memory of money your
relationship with money and let's just
go bare-bones budget keep your little
app let's actually look at it and then
we can start to address getting to that
big shiny object in the corner which is
the crypto in the stock market I was
gonna ask how does crypto and Bitcoin
fit into this really good question so
and especially at a time right now I've
I've never been more bullish for Bitcoin
and crypto overall and I am incredibly
fired up more now than I ever have for a
lot of reasons especially defined but
we'll get to that but I think right now
what you're seeing is when even younger
clients when they look at their
portfolio and they look at what's going
on you Steven people who've never
uttered the term money printing right
like that comes up in the conversation
well how is the government coming up
with the money for my stimulus check
they can give everybody two hundred
right and then do our lanczos so people
are understanding that concept and then
you start to talk to them about an asset
that is not tied to any of that right
and they're they're intrigued they've
heard about it they read
so for me it's just making sure people
get a solid education and foundation on
it again like I said as an advisor I've
never had to pitch Bitcoin in my life
all right like it sells itself
it doesn't need us so I just once that
awareness comes about and it's like a
almost like the thing with Bitcoin I
think it was just saying this I just
wrote a piece and he would say is like
once you see it you can't unsee it right
but so I feel like moving forward the
way I look at it long-dated call option
or a store value right now as we move
forward and these uncertain times and
you have just tweeted it's done
everything that was supposed to do in
this environment so right now it should
be a part of a conversation that
financial advisors are having with
clients institutions pension funds
whatever this is what you were looking
for because even myself on my walk in
talks I'm like listen y'all could happen
his parade Bitcoin has never been in a
recession right and then the world
literally falls apart and in its up so
it's like what now again short timeframe
but this is what you wanted to see now
what is it going to do over the next
five years so I think right now if we
were ever going to pitch this or talk
about it as something as sustainable as
a coronal cornerstone of a portfolio a
cornerstone of self sovereignty a
cornerstone of getting away from the
legacy banking system a cornerstone of
what it means to accumulate wealth and
be a part of the greatest wealth
transfer in history
now we double down on the conversation
about Bitcoin and especially to those
same people that we were saying were
left out of the legacy system now is
important to get this in front of them
at this very moment it's interesting
because maybe they are last year or so I
remember talking with a number of people
about the idea that what if bitcoins
adoption is the 180 degree opposite of
how technology has previously been
adopted so if you think of most
companies in the internet age they've
built products in the United States
they've kind of traded the US market
have a big board meeting and say you
know you 2020 is the year of
international expansion and they go and
they open up all these other markets
right oh Bitcoin on day one was global
anyone anywhere could use it and the
decentralized nature helped but actually
what we see in a lot of markets is
areas that are developing or
underdeveloped or not developed at all
that's where adoption occurs because
people literally see your point they
know the problems you don't have to
convince them that there's a problem
they actually know that the problem
exists here's a solution well you're
really describing is like wait a minute
that's not a developed nation or
developing nation thing that's literally
here in the United States there's 20 30
% of population same situation they the
second they hear about Bitcoin they say
hey that solves the problem that I've
had I just didn't even know that the
solution existed 100% this is what I've
been saying forever crypto is missing
its product market fit in the u.s. like
there's there's millions of people that
could use this I walked into a Waffle
House shout out the wonderful house on
my wife loved it shout to Jason I walk
into a Waffle House and Charlotte and I
had a by BTC shirt on and the the woman
ringing up she goes beat by BTC what's
that
I said his Bitcoin she goes oh I know
Bitcoin that's in my cash right and then
I took the time to educate her on what
it was she said what is it can you
explain it to me right and I'm like me
give me another waffle for sure but but
what I explained it to her and she got
it right away because that group of
people don't they don't trust banks
everything we're saying crypto as
opposed to before it's those people we
need to take it to them
they don't trust banks they rely is
super expensive for them to bank
themselves and act in and come you know
have commerce and interact outside of
the legacy banking system and oh by the
way I was saying this local bitcoins is
a gift to the inner city especially
those of us that are familiar with the
Susu which is basically a the first
blockchain if you ask me it goes all the
way back right to dutch slaves in the
16th century where we are there's ten
people we all put in a quote unquote
hand $100 right and then everyone takes
a turn getting the pot and then it's
scheduled I'll get mine this week pump
gets his next week there's no we trust
each other there's no third party all we
know is we're in the same community it's
trustless cuz I know you know I need to
pay my rent don't jerk me right and I
know you need to
your car no I'm not gonna jerk you and
that's how it works right and there's no
there's no credit checks there's nothing
that's how the inner city and a
Caribbean folks in every community has
their own that's how they built they
bought houses they bought cars they sent
their kids to school like and we're
completely unaware of that and then you
add in local bitcoins anyone that is
down there people that that's just call
them Oracle's right for the sake of this
conversation it's set up and run the
Susu they should be educated on local
bitcoins because what it means for
remittance is what it means to be able
to turn that money into Bitcoin or into
the local currency
it's Craigslist for Bitcoin like that
should be pitched to the inner city and
rural communities where they are in
banking deserts why are we still on
every crypto podcast and conference
talking about Argentina in Africa I love
Africa
I love Argentina but we have our own in
this country that are sucking wind they
just don't have access to the banking
let's go help them and then we can go
overseas and then take pictures and you
know whatever act like we're doing this
worldly good we can't but you take care
I was raised you take care of your home
first then you go somewhere else so I
just wish we would direct our focus and
especially right now because we could
pull so many people up with the power of
blockchain and the power of crypto but
we just need to direct our focus a bit
I'm not gonna make you debate the upside
or downside of Waffle House but I will
tell you I saw a tweet recently that
said you're telling me that Waffle House
is better at solving conflict than the
police side and I was dying right they
were like what House employees been
solving conflict at 3:00 a.m. with drunk
people forever no guns no no anything
like that like they're good at it they
like hire some of them right hood you
know better them employees will wear you
out
you catch a serious beatdown and they'll
still make sure you get your waffle like
a group of financial advisors fit in all
this right in terms of we know financial
education is problem we
go solve that we know crypto can be a
part right whether there's a small part
a big part whatever of the solution but
what are financial advisors fit in
and/or we had a position where financial
advisors can go do kind of the more
traditional financial education but
they're not yet up to speed on Bitcoin
and crypto or they're more and more
people getting up to speed like how do
you look at the financial adviser part
of all this great question so financial
advisors again I will admit I'm an
advisor we're complicit for the most
part of an industry because we sell our
services to the rich like I said but as
far as crypto goes if you look at when
the years started it was all about how
do we get financial advisors in the pool
and I said that was gonna be the theme
of 2020 the last conference I was at TD
Ameritrade the whole shows there Rick
Adelman Mike Novogratz right
matt hogan and myself and I was the last
to speak on crypto I had a 15 minute
presentation and I spoke to financial
advisors I said it's gonna be way
different from what you heard before I'm
not talking about no one percent
allocation I'm gonna be talking about
how this actually works into your
practice because I've built a full
practice on crypto away from from the
traditional means meaning I don't
custody with TD my clients custody away
from me
so anyway the issue here is that
everyone now is trying to figure out
what fact is where the Gateway we're the
Gateway to billions of dollars right in
some cases of dollars of retail assets
there's it problem is twofold one the
legacy and I say legacy crypto folks
don't realize that advisors are
uninterested until one they know they're
not gonna get sued or fired and how do I
get paid right so those are the things
that are missing right now so also
toward the mr. Pierre Rashard yourself
safar lavera I keep going I love every
single one of y'all you it mean it falls
on deaf ears to advisors they just don't
and you probably have the most cachet
amongst our group but they just it the
messenger matters here so until
financial advisors get the message from
someone that they trust and the
conversation around crypto is here's how
it works into your workflow this is what
custody looks like and by the way for
financial advisors
the fidelity is it hard stop when it
comes to custody
I love Gemini hi I love fidelity it
stops there why for no other reason and
Trust they trust fidelity and they have
probably their firms custody with
fidelity as well and I've had great
conversations with sinaner TD and a few
others but what then needs to happen for
financial advisors to really get serious
about this and again is the education so
if I just don't want to be educated on
what the housing is they don't want to
be educated on sha-256 keep that we need
to be educated on ok give me some right
and there was a kid devar name but
representative from fidelity digital
assets was just on with Nick Carter on
the brink podcast she said there's a
couple of things that institutions care
about 3 biggest things that's the thing
I care about I don't care about all of
the hope iam what are the concerns it's
the same thing financial advisors have
the volatility market manipulation and
in the last is fundamentals how do I
value it so again I love coin metrics I
love Delphi Delphi best in the game
Shelton sound to Delphi right they do
the best research in the game you cannot
give that to a financial advisor
they can't draft it and comprehend it
and then pass that on run through their
compliance and to on to a client so we
need to create content for them that
they feel comfortable learning from and
Delphi is probably best in class there
right and I've had some conversations
with them and then being able to pass
that on to a client so I think there's a
there's an education gap here that's not
happening and again the messenger
matters right even you know with the
best the best of Ana crypto space if you
put them in a Merrill or Morgan or
Goldman right the advisors gonna be like
right but if you put someone to date
trust which is why in Edelman Arana
Carson
I'm already big now Peter Mallick Josh
Brown right when those guys really start
to come to the pool and to the party
like in Josh's dance around and I love
them but I'm like come on man just come
all-in right but until they really start
to say okay we are literally going
all-in with our clients here and I think
a lot of it
which is why visors one a big coin ETF
but also ok fine we have a big coin ETF
we figure that out how do I then pull
that into my model so that I can create
a portfolio for a client that I can show
them and I could do a financial plan and
I can run through compliance and all
these are things no one are really
addressing that issue and why because
they're not financial advisors so they
don't know our individual concerns and
what clients are going to say which is
why I tell advisors a couple things
client walks at the door I own $50,000 a
Bitcoin and you asked him where coinbase
great best house bad neighborhood you
should slide a hardware wallet across
the table crypto assets by Crispin s key
and say we're gonna get to that but for
right now
how much do you own why do you own it
right go back to your investment policy
statement your risk tolerance go through
all of that with the client how tech
savvy are they go through that whole
thing then say okay well we need to work
on helping you get that off of coinbase
right there's a trust and a state issue
here right that client needs to update
their digital fiduciary right what are
they doing with the crypto cold storage
all these other things those are the
things that not address for financial
advisors so the interest is there but
the conversation is not built for them
no one's building for advisors education
is not for advisors but again shout the
Delphi interacts as a few others that
are starting to come there but until
financial advisors are comfortable with
that FINRA the SEC give more guidance
around where they could dance it's a
non-starter yeah I mean look and some of
this is just gonna get solved by time
and some of its gonna be people actually
taking the effort right to build some of
this stuff I want to end the podcast
with with one question which I think
most people have i'ma leave it fairly
open-ended because I think this applies
to everything from the economic shock to
police brutality and some rights to find
treasure case we're talking about which
is what can I do right and what can I do
where I've seen people ask this question
is around two things one how do I help
and in some form or fashion they will
also ask me although they won't say it
explicitly what should I not
right and they're very worried about
kind of doing for the sake of doing but
doing the wrong thing and so maybe you
can kind of just from your seat how do
you see the we'll call it quick or
average person listens the podcast on
Twitter etc what can they do to be part
of the solution great question so again
we are going to come out of this with a
wholehearted arm-in-arm
effort by all people but I think we have
to start with who are you right if you
are black we need more people in
positions of power right we need people
making the decision so all of this money
is raised right now we can say put it
here folks like myself with a platform
we have to bring light to you know Meis
me being told at one point if I'm gonna
make it on Wall Street I need to change
my name from Tyrone to Tyler right being
called an n-word right to my face right
like we need to speak truth to our
situation and bring light to these
things so I think it's a lot of it is
dependent upon who you are but I would
encourage all of us that are black
Americans one is now we need to leverage
our resources connect with one another
network but we need to get in positions
of power we need to go get our own we
need economic empowerment we need to
Bank black right we need to really be
supporting those that are in this
business right black advisers need to
connect black surgeons black you know
black accountants right and we need to
come together and build infrastructure
to support our own communities because
if you look at the data we all know it's
there no matter what you want to pull
right America gets the flu I mean
America gets sick the black community
gets the flu we've been affected most by
cold in all these things we need to go
get our own if you're not black and you
want to be an advocate for this message
I think one of the things that I have
been encouraging people to do is again
you are a great example of that using
your voice if you have one right and
again if you're my friend you're my
friend when I'm not in the room right
and then you can say oh that joke was
out of line right if that's you and you
and you have that that voice in that
room do that if it's simply saying like
I got dm's we're like
like taro look I'm not gonna do anything
publicly but I will move a few of few
million dollars to one United Bank right
which is the largest black bank in
America I'm with that everybody don't
need to be public the other thing is if
you want to do things in your community
do things that are gonna be literally
proactive and immediate right in the
community right so that could be an
after-school program that could be used
services that could be going down to you
know a homeless shelter whatever the
case may be it's just literally saying
and I tell people just walk in they say
what do you need all we need socks we
need this we need that like and and and
that's how this starts to work you just
literally got get out of your comfort
zone and I think the next thing is this
and I and I make no secret about this
and I have it I am only sitting here and
this is fact because of white people
especially a white woman who took a
flyer on me when I interviewed for this
job on Wall Street at the time I was a
juvenile probation officer and she said
to Terry she goes how does being a
juvenile probation officer gonna help
you on Wall Street and I was like that
is a really good interview question I
have no idea but I don't remember how I
answered the question but she took a
flier on me right she's like here's a
little black boy who is literally
illiterate we're gonna help him we're
gonna undergird him help him develop his
skills right and I think if everyone
does that because again like I said this
is a class issue this is a race issue
but if people stop feeling uncomfortable
going to the other side of town
patronizing some of those businesses and
going in there and transacting with them
and getting into the community right
then you'll find very unique ways to
help and I'll end it like this
if I'm drowning I don't care about the
color and a life preserver man I'm don't
you throw me a yellow life preserver and
I'm drowning okay no no go get a red one
I don't like yellow right so your color
does not matter right white people get
uncomfortable going to an all-black
school and like all I'm the only white
one here well guess what it's like that
for us every day so just you know and if
you are
comfortable going into the into the
inner city or into mostly black
communities DM me I'll go with you
right like I will go with you I've made
that commitment to all of my colleagues
but you reached out to me like listen
let me reach out to a black dude and be
like hey what should I say here like no
use a Malcolm X quote right so it's so
it's like just be comfortable reaching
out and yes so long as you are open
honest and an altruistic with your with
your desire to help I'll go to the end
of the world and so many like me will
but I just think we need to get over
having these tough conversations again
if you're gonna donate donate
effectively reach out like hey right
Wall Street bound out or a really good
organization again these are you can ask
or DM me or you or whatever we can start
to shed light if you put your downloads
here they're gonna be effective because
there have been so many boots on the
ground doing this work for a very long
time and those of us that are in the
trenches with them they're one issue is
they're under funded they're underfunded
so we need to make sure that all it is
you know Goldman pledged what ten
million which is a bad day of trading
for them right like that ten million
dollars we need to say goldman put it
here here's a program in new york city
they've been helping inner-city kids
with financial literacy they need fifty
grand
could you spare it right so if we don't
do that and that may just be simply diem
and emailing connecting people you don't
have to be out front you just connect
the people that can get the people that
are close to the issue and that's how
we'll get this solved and again kudos to
you for making room for this
conversation and i think and again i
promise i'm done here that's the thing
that's how this gets fixed yours your
megaphone is massive if you don't take
that seriously now and then use it to
amplify and message because the littlest
things it amazes me the things that
people pull out of your podcast and I
see on Twitter and I'm like I'll go back
to the interview I'm like where the hell
it travis clean say that you know but
people listen and then they go act on
that so i think you make a room for this
conversation is how is fixed reaching
out you know having different voices and
people that look differently different
perspective is how we get
fix but more importantly everybody go in
your community what can I do in my
community right now and if everyone does
that
we'll pull each other out of this
together and it will find that one mind
that is going to lead us out of this and
is going to be the leader that this
country is so void oh I love it
I'm gonna leave you with with something
that I can't say who it is but it's
somebody that I really respect and
somebody did not expect to say this to
me once said to me they said the thing
that everyone forgets is that living
doesn't happen in ivory towers it
happens in the streets and when they
said that to me I had a sit and think
for a second and I asked him a follow-up
question which is how do you internalize
that every day and he said he's
literally sitting in an ivory tower
pretty much and he said there are things
that I do to never lose the pulse of
what happens on the streets and I
remember going home and thinking about
it and I knew enough about the guys live
to understand it he wasn't talking about
just philanthropic things either right
he did plenty of dad donate money time
all's custom but he also understood
culture comes from the street he
understood that user behavior around
technology and understanding the
investments he shouldn't shouldn't make
came from the streets right and all
these things and I was recently reminded
of this because Flynn and I went
somewhere and we were there it was a
very different crowd than you would then
you would expect and it had nothing to
do with race or any of that it literally
had to do with lifestyle right there was
a small town every single person we saw
was obese every single person right and
I'm not talking about like hey that
person should lose 10 pounds and be
healthier I'm talking about that
person's a hundred pounds overweight
type stuff right and we started to look
around and we were like what why is that
why is it in this small town in a pretty
rural area and then you see the food
choices yeah McDonald's Bojangles gonna
listen you're like every single place
here is unhealthy like
if you wanted to eat healthy you can
cook at home or that's it by the way if
you want to eat cheap the only thing
that you can do is go to fast food and
so it's unhealthy and like and you can
just see here's the locket right here it
is but those are the same people that
are spending tons of time on technology
products culture right all this kind of
stuff and so I think that like that one
quote of living happens on the streets
there's this stuck with me of it is just
as much valuable to the people that you
are spending time with as it can be to
the people who are donating the time the
money their whatever right there there
are things to learn if that curiosity is
there and so I always remind people that
like it doesn't have to be a one-way
street right you may actually go and
extract more value than you give by
accident one right and honestly that may
be a good thing right all right where
can uh where can people find you on the
internet where do we want to send them
all right here's where we want to send
them right off the bat at TR 401 that's
where I live that's where I chop it up
with pomp on time also run to my website
Tyrone Ross dot IO also check out 401 .
run which is my company site there but
there between those three you can get
connected and again anybody to got
feedback won't help anything they want a
partner to make this happen hello at
Tyrone Ross tayo you can email me for
sure you're a legend not only one for
everything you do but to you came on
with the long Bitcoin short too bad I
had to man again if all you've done for
me amplify my voice to gratitude the
appreciation I cannot express enough you
doing guys work man he's gonna hold you
up I appreciate so much awesome I will
do it again soon a doubt man I
appreciate you